I mean literally on a seat fire blazing
smoke going inside the Train
[Music]
so I was heading to work so it's taking
the 6:00 train so this was primetime
rush hour there's barely any seats
everyone's kind of in a miserable mood I
end up getting all the way at the edge
of the Train where the windows right
here then there's a little space and
then there's another cab I'm sitting
with my girlfriend and she's talking to
me and I kind of zoned out for a second
I'm staring through the window into the
other car and then I see this lady
coming towards the door and I don't
really think of anything other I'm kind
of just like bracing because I get a
little nervous when the doors open up so
I'm bracing for the other door to open
up it doesn't open up where is this lady
so I see her in the middle of the train
cars so I'm looking around and no one
else is noticing so I'm getting a little
nervous
I go to my girlfriend I was like do you
see this person in the middle of the
train she's like yeah whatever it and I
was like all right never mind I go back
to listening to the story and I look out
the window again and this lady has now
dropped her trousers and is using the
restroom in the middle of the train
right there and not just number one but
number two it was in between the two
train cars while moving in the danger
zone and where I'm sitting is actually a
very terrible vantage point but the
worst part about the whole story is I'm
looking in the other train I'm looking
around I'm looking at my girlfriend I
was like is anybody else seeing this
right now or is it just me as soon as I
figure out what's going on I tap her on
the shoulder I'm like look what she's
already done holds up her trousers goes
back on the other train sits back down
and I swear to you that the person she
sat next to gave this horrific look like
he just smelled like something died and
I was just like well I'm the only one
that noticed that that just happened I
was in East Village I was gonna take the
F train back into Queens it was 2:00 in
the morning 2:30 in the morning and the
train came in I hopped in a car and
everyone started hearing people yelling
fire fire clearly we weren't gonna be
going anywhere but I like held on hope I
was like I'm just gonna sit here this
might just be a fluke it wasn't a fluke
everyone got out it was two cars down
there was smoke I actually had a friend
that was on the other side that called
me I was like hey there's a legit fire
in the car there's like oh [ __ ] so I ran
over to the car and true to form there
was a crowd of people their phones were
ripped out I whipped out my phone and
there was a fire on the scene in the
Train none of us left a bunch of us just
stayed when you got out of the station
there were fire trucks everywhere and
they had closed down a couple streets
and clearly I wasn't going to get home
it was just random and entertaining even
though I probably shouldn't have thought
of it that way I recently moved to New
York so I'm not super familiar with the
city and I'm just kind of going about my
way and my commute to work at this time
was probably about 30 to 40 minutes and
as I was walking up on the platform I
was approaching some quite steep stairs
and suddenly this like enormous pressure
smacked me in the back of the neck and I
fell to the ground I just collapsed and
didn't actually really have the time to
like turn around and figure out what had
gone on because my phone was smashed my
bag had fallen down the floor and
everyone was looking what had happened
is this guy he has said that I had
budged into him previously on my commute
and he had turned around got himself
very worked up and found me and ran at
full speed pushed me super super hard in
the back of my neck so I fell down so at
this point I've turned around not really
knowing what's going on I looked up at
him and he was the seething
incredibly angry kind of glazed over
kind of like some alpha male character
in a murder film but he was still angry
and still proud so he was like standing
over me going Aion he was like it just
popped into me so I was like apologizing
profusely this guy just kept repeating
that I had barged into him someone else
asked him to calm down someone else was
helping me up off the floor and then I
apologized I said listen I'm really
sorry and then he went to work and then
I went to work and just start my desk
had a cup of tea and didn't tell anyone
and then a couple days later I was like
actually that's really dramatic
[Music]